hola bienvenidos una vez más a esta
emisión canadá en las américas café el
programa de la sección en español de
radio canadá internacional que les
proponemos cada semana cada viernes en
directo a través de nuestro sitio en
internet y a través de youtube y los
sábados y domingos pueden encontrar la
emisión como es habitual en nuestro
sitio en internet www rc y net punto sea
y por supuesto una de las vías
tradicionales por las que nos sigue cada
vez más gente es facebook live así
aprovechamos a saludar a todos no sé por
qué cámara lo saludable desea saber
bienvenidos una vez más a todos los que
nos siguen entonces a través de facebook
live like perdón se suman también cada
vez más a aquellos que prefieren
seguirnos a través de youtube que es la
plataforma que hemos sumado
recientemente y bueno aquí estamos como
cada viernes proponiendo de este
encuentro en el cual ustedes forman
parte importante son la parte central de
esta emisión queremos escuchar sus
propuestas
sus inquietudes sus mensajes sus
demandas a las que prometemos siempre
darles cabida y a veces le damos aunque
no tal vez en la magnitud en la que
deberíamos la magnitud que esperan pero
qué tal que quieren que sea así como muy
sino bueno por ejemplo atendido que
sigue reaccionando a los artículos con
respecto a la inmigración y con respecto
al arreglarse los dientes en mensajes o
quien lo siguen por ahí hacemos
artículos específicos sobre cuestiones
que tienen que ver con la salud el
tratamiento nuevos tratamientos para no
sé por ejemplo la diabetes y alguien nos
escribe donde encuentro el médico cómo
hago para contactarme cómo hago para el
tratamiento y bueno en ese caso no
tenemos las herramientas bueno siga
viendo sus mensajes así que si es verdad
de lo que iba a decir es que en realidad
cuando nos envían esos mensajes si se
refieren al artículo como tal hay
información que ya está incluida en el
artículo que está en nuestro sitio
internet y bueno también hay autoridades
que se encargan de todas las cuestiones
de migraciones
exactamente y antes de meternos en el
bueno para empezar no nos hemos
presentado hoy es una formación poco
poco tradicional la que tenemos aquí
apelando al vocabulario deportivo esto
de formación no te gusta el poco
habitual que estemos aquí en el estudio
yo no era chapman o la paloma martínez
hola leonardo gimeno encantado y mi
nombre es luis laborda vistan a docentes
otros permanentes de esta sección
habitual como pablo gómez barrios y rufo
valencia siempre 62
pero bueno
pero si le gusta lo sabe no no no no soy
tanto como me gustaría decir
no hay que hacer un poco de deporte no
solamente
y más allá de estas charadas que hacemos
nosotros aquí para comenzar y romper el
hielo cuáles son los temas que le han
llamado la atención fuera de la
actualidad porque esta es una semana
aquí vino cargada en lo que hace
actualidad tanto en el plano local como
internacional hay una información de
esas poco habituales poco frecuentes
me dio mucha angustia y sleep murcia de
snap chat
es un artículo de la bbc de londres en
español es el fenómeno por el que cada
vez más pacientes de cirugía estética se
miran a parecerse a sus propios selfish
con filtros lo he visto porque en
snapper lo que hay son son muñequitos y
hay un montón de filtro
pero no necesariamente el muñeco sino el
filtro entonces yo me sacó una foto y me
arreglo con filtro suaviza la piel
estiró el mentón cuando publican sus
fotos
parece que el procedimiento es el
inverso hay casos de gente que ha ido
con la foto de su snap chat y le dijo el
cirujano plástico yo quiero esto vaya ya
eso es un problema muy grave
[Risas]
el loco realmente o sea que la gente
arregle su cara en una imagen y bata al
cirujano plástico le digo yo quiero esto
pero si usted con un par de filtro bueno
quiero que me aplique los filtros bueno
hay gente que ha hecho cirugías
estéticas
por los llamados de alguna manera para
poder destrozar personajes de
historietas exacto cuando ya pude
imaginar el resultado la barbie por
ejemplo es aquella que se parece que se
parecerá a la barbie después el súper
hiper conocido cantante que falleció
hace un par de años y no más al ave
están y por conocidos que no me acordé
nombre michael jackson que se hizo mil
operaciones primero era para ser blanco
y después para parecerse no sé a quién y
después para no sé cuánto y después han
salido gente de la piel que se volvía
blanco manchas blancas es lo que hizo
fue como pareja
así pero modificar el mentón la nariz la
frente el peinado tiene que ver con las
manchas blancas que tenía noticias pero
que realmente no tienen nada que ver
con canadá tampoco pero que me hizo reír
muchísimo y que este hombre dijo yo a
eso no quiero a diferencia de lo que
dice leonardo es un señor en áfrica en
un país africano por poco importa el
lugar que tenía problemas para hacer
pipí entonces se fue a ver al médico y
el médico analizando su problema se dio
cuenta de que el hombre pues se le dijo
usted es estéril desde que nació yo
tenía diez hijos como él llegó a la casa
que llegó a la casa después de haber
criado nueve hijos y hecho a los nueve
hijos y a la mujer
en mendoza de una persona tenía cuatro
hijos y se separó de su mujer la madre
de sus cuatro hijos quiso encargar un
bebé con la nueva y no podía no podía no
podía y él le decía con toda la
liviandad del mundo
el problema debe ser tuyo fueron juntos
porque los crío durante tantos años y
vos dices es que no les tiene cariño
ya mí sí me llamó la atención otra cosa
que sucede en manitoba en una región de
manitoba entre el lago manitoba y el
lago winnipeg hay una zona de calcárea
de piedras calcáreas que están por abajo
de los lagos y entre los dos lagos en
donde duermen bueno y berman durante
todo el invierno
culebras de rayas si bajo el agua bajo
la tierra pero entre los dos lagos vaya
a estar están en una zona que es
bastante grande entre dos lagos
gigantescos en la provincia de manitoba
y allí viven un montón de culebras pues
resulta ser que esas culebras cuando
salen en la primavera al final de abril
y principios de mayo como las flores
porque entran en una en un momento que
alguna área
quieren aparearse y hay pocas mujeres
pocas hembras con respecto a la cantidad
de macho los machos son más pequeños las
hembras son más grandes y más como
voluptuosas pero cuando salen todas
estas serpientes estás culebras crean el
la reunión más grande de culebras del
mundo en canadá es un récord pero la
diferencia que uno dice aquí te traje la
versión
de culebras
no creo que tampoco sea muy agradable
escucharse con semejante cantidad de
culebras
entonces si buscan un videíto pongan así
en google o en una los buscadores de
internet culebras winnipeg o culebras y
mares
y claro el sitio de jersey que está ahí
no es cierto lo hizo y me dice es no es
un lugar muy poblado no no no no hay
mucho lago y sitio a un lado pero por
culo y quien se dio cuenta de la
cantidad enorme de gente que quiera
pasear así por el bosque era un congreso
pero hablábamos de deportes hace algún
instante también y también esta noticia
no es específicamente de canadá pero
ocurrió aquí será que con un deporte que
tiene sus adeptos también aquí en canadá
y ya llegando el buen tiempo este
deporte también florece que seguro
la información que surgió se vio un
vídeo circulando por internet durante
los últimos dos o tres días no tengo ya
aquí la foto pero vamos a ver si la
ponemos en nuestro sitio de internet de
este jugador de golf que estaba tomando
parte de un torneo entre el escudo que
se llama eeuu la escuela preparatoria
que es ese ciclo que es introductorio a
la universidad no es eeuu este golfista
de un equipo de una escuela preparatoria
de michigan de golpe cuando estaba
tomando parte en el inicio de este
torneo se vio corrido atacado picoteado
pateado y desalojado por el juego por un
ganso
[Risas]
parece ser que el animal se vio invadido
como dice ahora
y se después no alumno se le tiró la
cabeza lo patio no ocurrió
ya tenía alcanzado encima
sí fue bastante cómica es cómica la
secuencia verdadera que es que le
estaban estaban met es como que alguien
se mete en tu casa
la misma reacción y yo traía a colación
el tema precisamente porque en eeuu los
campos de golf suelen ser más utilizados
durante la totalidad del año no sé si en
todos los estados unidos supongo que en
el norte no pero porque tiene un clima
bastante similar al nuestro pero en la
zona central y hacia el sur de eeuu los
campos de golf funcionan casi todo el
año la mayor parte del año aquí no era
aquí solamente en verano y si no lo han
retomado ya creo que no porque no
escuchados
tiene que estar por volver a la
actividad muy pronto se han vuelto
tengan cuidado
no son los que nada gus son los gansos
ahí es mi esposo trabaja en una escuela
en el oeste de la isla y tienen un
cantero no es muy grande el [ __ ]
pterois todos los años hay una pata
danza danza que llega y se acomoda en
ese cantero el año pasado puso un huevo
y se queda quieta y pasan los chicos la
saludan y se sacan fotos el fish con la
gansa la gansa y no la hay la toca por
supuesto con un gancho salvaje y este
año poco lo hacia sebha hace varios años
y este año el ganso es más chiquito y la
gente de la escuela sospecha que es el
hijo o la hija porque no tienen vida muy
larga estos animalitos tienen 34
especialidades 34 años
entonces suponen que es la hija que está
haciendo la misma rutina y viene
empollar
evito la puerta de la escuela así que le
gusta la escuela es el lugar tiene su
lugar bueno los que se están jugando
golf yo solo todo que sea antes de que
nos vayamos a uno de los equipos de
hockey de canadá porque ya están siendo
los únicos pero los canadienses hace
rato que se fue de toronto se acaban de
ir en una p en una triste recomendando
deporte una vez que ellos cambian de
deporte según la temporada cuando acabe
jo aquí se van a jugar 4 y las malas
lenguas dicen que a veces quieren perder
rápido para no perderse el gol
si de verdad es una tradición bueno en
definitiva vi la anécdota valga quienes
sean adeptos al golf por estas tierras y
estén ya sacándole brillo a sus palos
para ir a practicar el su deporte
favorito ideado con el gancho y cuiden
de los gansos que está bien
[Música]
bueno para no incumplir como hago yo
siempre cada vez que me toca coordinar
esta emisión con nuestros oyentes que
están si leemos antes de adentrarnos en
los temas aunque sea cada uno uno o dos
mensajes de los que nos hacen llegar
nuestro señor nuestro público cada
semana porque tenemos muchos aquí
tenemos uno que dice perdón en paloma de
hoy de respirar cuando lo he empezado a
hablar
canadá y su plan de inmigración 2018 luz
stella o riesgos al azar nos dice hola
yo de colombia mi nombre es luz ortega
soy madre de cinco hijos desplazada por
la violencia y junto con mi pareja
queremos inmigración a canadá somos de
escasos recursos económicos que podemos
hacer para obtener la residencia gracias
espero respuesta entonces a luz stella
le decimos lo que a la mayoría la mejor
manera es ir a consultar a las embajadas
de canadá en carbono los países ellos
tienen los datos específicos y si no
entrando en internet si maneja un poco
de inglés un poco de francés inclusive
creo que está en español la información
preliminar para la inmigración pueden
hacerlo también en línea
perfecto tengo un comentario sobre una
entrevista con john ackerman sobre lópez
obrador el candidato a las elecciones en
mexico y escribe rosa amarilla y dice
felicidades al doctor germán por hablar
con tanta certeza y verdad para que con
ello tengan allá otra perspectiva de lo
que realmente está pasando en esta
patria mexicana tan vapuleada por el pri
durante 90 años perfecto como un mensaje
que llega comentando el tema continúa la
mortífera represión de israel contra
manifestantes palestinos y gabriel dice
israel defiende sus fronteras y los
manifestantes no solo se exponen sino
que además los provocan con actos
violentos para ellos la vida no vale
nada qué pasaría si la manifestación
fuera en otro país seguramente habría
miles de muertos dice gabriel comentando
este tema continúa la mortífera
represión de israel contra manifestantes
palestinos bueno es otro mensaje que nos
hace llegar gonzalo torres sobre el tema
canadá y su plan de inmigración 2018 que
es un tema que ha merecido muchísimos
mensajes en los últimos días en nuestro
sitio de internet y él nos pregunta o
nos dice mejor dicho me gustaría si se
puede una copia de la ley de inmigración
para compararla con la chilena y ver las
diferencias para un foro supongo que
estará planeando un foro de discusión
sobre inmigración en chile de donde él
es oriundo y que entonces comparar la
ley migratoria chilena con la ley de
inmigración en canadá bueno como decía
leonardo en el sitio en el sitio
internet de inmigración de internar al
gobierno esto porque si es la ley sobre
inmigración que es la que estará en el
sitio del gobierno de canadá que muchas
veces tienen otras lenguas también y
debe ser fácil de bajar una copia de la
misma es probable que se consiga
fácilmente de aquí tengo sobre el mismo
tema jean ya que escribe s tengo 30 años
me es posible estamos sufriendo porque
porque ser más joven me niega en la
residencia permanente o visa de turismo
en fin mi esposo y yo no sabemos qué
hacer para vivir juntos sólo estamos
haciendo que termine en esta ocasión
porque no puedo yo no podría ir a canadá
como hacemos pregunta quien nos brinda
ayuda creemos que no es justo que por la
edad nieguen a alguien vivir juntos
gracias debe haber algún otro tipo de
cosas
más si tiene 30 años de migración es una
pareja joven de 30 años confiable de
tener hijos y creo que debe ser otro el
tema independientemente de eso habría
que llamar a las autoridades o ir a
preguntar en el caso este ala
digamos oficina más cercana donde a don
consulado de canadá para preguntar cuál
es el problema para saber qué corregir
en el caso de que se pueda corregir
efectivamente yo no tengo acá sobre un
tema que sí creo que lo mencionaste
louis sobre un programa de dentistas
canadienses para mujeres marginales
escribe ya clint desde lima perú nos
dice que es madre de tres niños que no
puede hablar en público porque no tiene
perdió sus dientes que su vida cambió
radicalmente y que no cuenta con las
posibilidades económicas porque es madre
soltera para hacerse los dientes
entonces pide ayuda entonces bueno este
es un programa y como el título lo
indica es un programa de dentistas
canadienses para mujeres marginales aquí
de canadá así si uno lee el reportaje
entonces lamentablemente esto no
funcionaría con gente que no vive en
canadá pero seguramente tiene que haber
planes a viene si dos habíamos visto en
algún momento con leonora por qué es ese
artículo lo hiciste vos si no me
equivoco hace ya mucho tiempo si nos nos
fijamos hicimos una pequeña búsqueda
sobre internet
y otros programas similares es cuestión
de buscar solo si yo tengo aquí un
mensaje que responde a un reportaje de
pablo que se llamaba que llevaba el
título lola o un mundo que se extingue
que era un reportaje sobre una película
me parece con una sobreviviente de los
selk'nam es un pueblo indígena de la
tierra del fuego y son wax que tiene una
dirección que comienza con marcela
entonces lo mejor imagino que el nombre
en castellano sería marcela de esta
persona que comenta dice mi pueblo
selknam no fue exterminado seguimos en
pie si hubo un genocidio pero no
exterminio que roza en pueblos elham
dice ella o me imagino que se llama
marcela son wax nos escribe comentando
el tema que pablo presentó lola o un
mundo que se extingue que está en
nuestro sitio interpreta bueno querías
de algo más si en realidad tengo otro en
este caso más crece lópez obrador en
sondeos más con del pan y con washington
john ackerman de javier gonzález nunca
que nos dice amigo verse y en méxico
gobernado el pri el pan y regreso al pri
con peña nieto- nos han dejado mal se
abren la boca con sus malos gobiernos
hoy en día el señor lópez obrador aunque
también proviene del pri el pueblo
mexicano tiene muchas esperanzas para
con él en las redes sociales se nota
esta preferencia yo como taxista lo
palpó cuando platico con mis clientes
pero amigos todavía faltan unos meses
para la elección y pueden pasar muchas
cosas una gran campaña en contra de
lópez obrador en méxico actualmente
efectivamente vamos a volver más tarde
los mensajes de nuestros oyentes pero
ahora nos vamos a dedicar a la
actualidad aunque sea en un tramo de
esta emisión como dijimos al comienzo la
semana vino cargada en temas de
actualidad tanto aquí en canadá como en
el exterior y lamentablemente el caso al
que nos tenemos que referir en lo que
hace a la información canadiense es el
del hecho desgraciado trágico y
bochornoso vergonzoso no sé cuántos
calificativos más podrían cubrir lo
ocurrido el lunes último en la ciudad de
toronto en la que una persona con una
camioneta de alquiler en vistió contra
transeúntes y numerosas arterias más
concurridas de esa ciudad que vaya a
decir lo toronto
ciudad más poblada de canadá
y la más multicultural y la más
multicultural según se dice sí y bueno
el saldo que dejó este acto es tráfico
10 personas muertas
no estoy seguro ahora me duro si son 15
o 14 los encantados heridos y 10 muertos
i
hasta ahora se sabe es bastante poco de
las razones aunque algunas puntas ya
comenzaron a surgir que llevaron a esta
persona a cometer este acto que en
definitiva no es otra cosa que un acto
criminal y y hasta cierto punto tal vez
terrorista también es decir cuando uno
sabe que hay una idea detrás de ese esa
masacre y en este caso pues es una
persona que se manifestó como anti
feminista contra las mujeres y yo creo
que es la diferencia pues es muy muy
difícil pero sigue siendo terrible
terrorista también yo lo definiría como
un acto terrorista dirigido contra su
bronca contra las mujeres estamos
hablando de alec y minassian y es un
joven canadiense y como vos contaste un
poco la historia y que él en su sitio o
en una red social antes de cometer esta
barbarie publicó algo donde hacía
referencia a un estadounidense el que se
llama roger que es un zoom de 22
en el 2014 más o menos hizo lo mismo
arrasó con un auto impacto y él es el un
poco el que utiliza esta palabra ins els
que después la retoma el canadiense que
significa ser libres involuntarios son
hombres que le echan la culpa a las
mujeres de no poder que las mujeres no
les den importancia a ellos no tienen
relaciones casi de ninguna naturaleza
con mujer se sienten rechazados y este y
definen a los y ellos definen a los
hombres y mujeres que si tienen buenas
relaciones entre ellos las las llaman
para los hombres xavi a las mujeres
stacy's y entonces este canadiense
publicó en su sitio web hizo según la
prensa canadiense que lo destaca entre
otros radio canadá había puesto la
rebelión de los pinceles ya ha comenzado
vamos a acabar con todos los chats y los
y las stage y sin entonces más gente
ligada a este grupo reivindicó el ataque
lo calificó como un acto que debería
haberse hecho incluso antes hay un
mensaje de alguno de los participantes
de ese grupo de gente que dice que ojalá
esta persona que cometió el ataque de
canarias ya no financian publique un
manifiesto porque podría ser el próximo
santo de este grupo el próximo líder la
próxima figura líder de este grupo con
lo cual yo creo que ya hay elementos más
que suficientes para sí igual es algo
más simple pero esta gente estás
involucrado en un acto que
guayana con lo directivo porque he dicho
están ellos mismos apoyando un acto
criminal
y yo creo que la investigación policial
alrededor de este estas células de
personas es cada vez más entre comillas
sencilla porque se están mostrando y se
están publicando ellos mismos entre
ellos en las redes sociales
y son accesibles al público en general
entonces de alguna manera estas células
que existían con anterioridad y que eran
secretas y nadie conocía que existían
ahora están siendo más públicas tiene
sus lados buenos y sus lados malos
porque entre ellos se alimentan y se
retroalimentan y sus ideas horrorosas
como estas pues se contaminan a los
venden claro lo que decía una en una una
entrevista de radio canadá esta semana
también francine peltier que es una
periodista y es una realizadora y que
además ella estaba en una lista de para
hacer para ser asesinadas aquí en canadá
cuando se cometió la masacre de la
politécnica en el sitio del joven que
hizo este es es estos asesinatos estaba
el nombre de ella también y dijo algo
muy interesante también en radio canadá
y era que en este ella lo que está
observando es que desde que asumió te
rompe en eeuu estos grupos se dan la
libertad cada vez de manifestarse más no
es como dice paloma no es que no
existían antes existían pero no se daban
a conocer ahora es como quien se da se
permiten en general y son hombres
blancos jóvenes con problemas
relacionales con las mujeres y que
descargan pues sus
su ira dirigidas contra las mujeres o en
este caso contra todo el mundo porque si
vemos lo que hizo el canadiense
minassian pues mató a de estas diez
personas que van de 30 a 80 años
no son mujeres pero eso no fue calculado
porque cuando vas en la calle como en la
calle no puedes calcular arrasó y se da
la casualidad de que murieron más
mujeres que hombres si le decían también
es que le salió mal la jugada entre
comillas porque lo logró porque
pretendía que lo mataran para realmente
volver unido el claro como un mártir el
el hecho debe de haber muerto en
enfrentamiento con la policía del
policía canadiense con sangre fría de
jabón increíble yo vi el vídeo y vi
cuando el tipo este está en el auto y lo
provocaba y le decía tirarme porque
tengo ellas y además de sacar el arma y
el policía ni se movía su celular hacía
como si trajera una pistola en mano lo
cual era porque quería que ken la anp
que es el policía canadiense
y claro y no y el policía no le hizo el
juego pero qué sangre fría además hay
que verlo es bueno y en realidad dejó el
arma y sacó su bastón como sea meses
para lo que llevan los policías y si se
le dice le acercó y lo hilo y entonces
ahí el otro vio que no tenía nada que
hacer y se dice tiro al suelo y se
entregó pero podría haberlo matado
fácilmente y hubiera estado justificado
el saco la razón ahora los especialistas
numerosos especialistas que se
refirieron al asunto en los últimos días
en su mayoría se obtuvieron el mismo
argumento la misma idea es casi
imposible predecir mientras que de estas
características como se hace para evitar
que alguien tome un auto y agarrarse a
la gente en la calle no no no podemos
los urbanistas están están atacando sea
el problema es ese es estuve viendo un
poco el tema en el reino unido en nueva
york y ahora en columbia británica y
están ideando ya están trabajando sobre
el tema en las principales ciudades por
supuesto donde es donde estos hombres
atacan y están ideando ya cosas para
acción en los aceros
en los los dos pilotes y todo y entonces
están haciendo cosas muy particulares y
muy interesantes al proyecto si no vas a
poder impedir todo esto nomás al
problema de fondo porque en realidad el
problema de fondo es gente que está
frustrada
sí porque el problema yo creo que es la
convivencia entre las diferencias
cualquiera que fue que sean las
diferencias puntos de vista realidades
vividas por los demás entonces yo creo
que ahí es donde como cómo ir a tocar
esa gente que se siente frustrada hasta
ese punto tocarlos y explicarles si se
vive una de las cosas que me exhibición
a mí me llamó la atención
muchos de canadá cuando yo llegué es que
me contaban que no hay
hospitales para gente con enfermedad
mental es bueno si hay los hay pero son
temporales entonces si es una persona
porque en realidad son las personas
débiles de espíritu que tienen estos
problemas qué
que después salen con un regalo como
esto no todos tienen tendencias no la
mayoría no tiene tendencias asesinas hay
que decir por supuesto que el tema es
cómo hacer para detectarlo a tiempo
parece bueno pero eso crédito y un poco
el euro tocó también paloma pero tiene
que ver con lo que estamos viendo todos
aquí yo me refería a eso hace unos
instantes decir el grupo que difunde
estos mensajes por internet preguntó
creo yo yo tengo mi respuesta pero no sé
qué opinan ustedes no está haciendo
apología del delito pero yo no sé si eso
en eeuu está penalizado pero el canal
agenda debería estar penalizado acá el
discurso de odio está penalizada mentira
apología del delito no se encierre
dentro del discurso de la opción creo
que si no pueden entonces las
autoridades no sabemos qué es lo que
están haciendo los cálculos de ese tipo
de organizaciones son bastante grandes
bastante extensos y hay muchísimos ahora
lo que sí cree
y lo hacen con con células terroristas
de otros tipos la policía canadiense
tiene espías y tiene agentes dobles y
tiene gente trabajando hackeando los
sitios internet los grupos que son
supuestamente privados entonces si hay
ese trabajo lo que pasa es que es muy
difícil ir a buscar esas esas personas
que pueden eventualmente hacer un acto
terrorista en este caso por ejemplo que
habría sido factible sería todas las
personas que están en este grupo
haberles impedido que alquilar un auto
no es cuando tienes gente que participa
de este grupo de cual se refería
eleonora y difunde un mensaje que dice
por ejemplo la mayoría de vosotros solo
os dedicáis a hablar alabando el hecho
de que este opción de que es terminación
que se haya lanzado a la ala al acto y
haya plaza ha dejado únicamente el
discurso y pasado la acción este caso un
acto violento decir esta persona está
haciendo apología del delito
la policía de un crimen más esta persona
está cometiendo un delito
a esa persona se habría que ir a
buscarla podría irse a buscar con él de
este piso net por ejemplo que entró en
que también cometió una matanza yo creo
que tenía cosas en su sitio también de
internet y que la policía no puede andar
al tambor
todo el mundo tiene una computadora
puesto que decirme que me hace acordar
al caso de que ha habido en los últimos
tiempos lamentablemente algunos sobre
todo en eeuu el de familias que tienen
encerrada son sus hijos oa otros chicos
a los que han raptado y cuando esto
ocurre cuando esto salta a la luz
aparecen no 1 y 2 y 3 sino diez veinte
cincuenta vecinos
aunque había cosas que sí es verdad que
hay señales suficientes de que hay gente
que no pasa todos los días yo salí de
trabajar una tarde me fui caminando por
una avenida grande samarrá en el bec que
es donde se ubica el les emplaza el
edificio de la torre de radio canadá y
tres o cuatro cuadras hacia el centro de
la ciudad de montreal encuentra una
mujer tirada en el piso y casey llorando
yo me freno y me agacho la ilusión yo
necesita ayuda no puedo levantarme no
pudo caminar no por levantarme mientras
yo le preguntaba conté unas 78 personas
que pasaron ninguna se paró bueno pero
yo quiero decir eso tal vez es un evento
que sucedió pero yo cuando tuve un
accidente de bicicleta por dios
muchísima gente vino a ayudarme de
verdad nadie pasó por eso pero yo voy
por ejemplo esta persona que ya no está
en una bicicleta claro accidentado no lo
sabían
pero digamos como que hay una cultura
del otro y no sé si respetará es primero
respetar ponerle que aparezca por el
respeto pero después es como que no me
no me incumbe hay una barrera yo he
visto yo a mí me pasó dos veces donde
vino no soy yo la que se acercó hubo
gente que lo hizo más rápidamente y que
realmente ayudaron a una persona al etna
entró que estaba sentado y como que se
desvaneció la gente se le fue encima a
ayudarla y también otras en un accidente
de bicicleta en montreal yo vi que la
gente corría para ayudar entonces es
relativo
que es tan amplia la liamos el abanico
de cosas
y como la gente actúa que en realidad es
casi imposible si uno trata de detectar
este tipo de comportamientos en el caso
de eso que hay una apología del delito
me parece que debería ser ahora
no sabemos pero posiblemente esté la
policía está investigando eso lo que yo
creo nosotros no sabemos por qué además
no lo van a dar publicidad no sabe la
información oficial hasta el momento
sigue siendo a cuentagotas
no están investigando entonces más vale
que nos dan toda la información aquí
tengo saludos en realidad gente de
danielle camporini que nos está
sintonizando los saludos hacer de monroe
en buenos aires argentina y delfina de
hacker man también nos hace un saludito
saludamos y saludamos también a la gente
que está participando y hay otros que
están también mirando la emisión pero
que no han participado con sus palabras
bueno lo que no es tan amplio es el
espacio que nosotros tenemos para este
programa ya nos quedan apenas unos diez
minutos más o menos así que vamos a una
pausa y luego venimos con los temas que
hemos estado trabajando que ustedes han
estado trabajando esta semana
hola aquí les habla marco castillo
productor músico brasileño que vive en
winnipeg y los invito a escuchar canadá
en las américas café
la radio canadá internacional en la web
bueno perfecto los invitamos nosotros
también a que se sumen cada vez más ya
que nos hagan llegar sus inquietudes y
sus mensajes de felicitación también
porque explica pero también nos pueden
querer bueno vamos a presentar entonces
a nuestro auditorio los temas en los que
han estado trabajando esta semana al
menos un tema de los que han estado
trabajando esta semana quiero decir cuál
es el que les recomendamos el que les
destacamos el que quisiéramos que fueran
ya mismo en este instante a consultar ya
quién quiere comenzar ya mismo no porque
sale mañana
pero bueno
cuánta gente ustedes en la mesa que
tiene gmail yo no yo yo bueno
cambia nuevamente en realidad después de
11 después del año 2011 es el primer
cambio significativo que va a tener
gmail grande no grande pero interesante
que va a pasar en las grandes
organizaciones pues viendo en realidad
ese es el hecho justamente los cambios
están pensados para las grandes
organizaciones y para poder robarle y no
robarle o competir
digamos mal pensado
que es el jefe de los jefes en cuanto a
la sangría de correo electrónico y
cuando va a hacer eso y en este caso
para la gente común y corriente ya está
disponible uno tiene que ir a una
pestañita de arriba donde está la
pequeña ruedita de nuestra cara no no no
la ruedita prefieren de las preferencias
y poner el que muestre la nueva versión
versión y ya podemos usarla ya la puse
en mi personal es súper funcional
realmente tiene un montón de cositas y
después para la parte final es posible
que en oficina también no todavía porque
tiene que aceptarla
aceptar la gente de comptos primero y
después
nos pasó con la agenda la agenda que
nosotros manejamos cambió hace poquito
pero la agenda había cambiado ya hace
aproximadamente un año antes que
nosotros pudimos ponerla en
funcionamiento implantarla en nuestro
nos de más de un mes y medio del trabajo
en este caso hay cosas muy interesantes
para la cuestión del laboral justamente
con el nuevo gmail que elementos como
por ejemplo hacer un escribir un mail
que tenga fecha de caducidad
y que no se pueda ni copiar ni reenviar
cuando tenemos que mandar cosas que son
sensibles con información privada con
información que no quiero que se difunde
difunda lo mando de esa manera entonces
igual podían difundir si uno no tenía
esa cosa
ahora el destinatario una vez que lo
recibió y lo consumió exacto puede
autodestruirse como él
una vez que esta nota
para los servicios secretos pero para
nosotros no proponemos hechos legales si
por ejemplo o si por ejemplo uno tiene
hay gente que dice así que funcionemos
todo el mundo nos espía por la de
nosotros no es problema así que eso es
todo solamente para presentarles el
nuevo gmail y lo pueden ir a ver y
hablar de los cinco minutos que nos
quedaban perdón menos tiempo y ahora yo
tengo voy a ser rápida entonces se trata
de un neurólogo especialista en
epilepsia de la universidad de
saskatchewan es una historia muy
interesante él es un mexicano y yo
recibo mensajes a mancilla están
llegando mensajes
él se llama jose francisco téllez
centeno es un especialista en neurología
epilepsia de epilepsia es profesor de
medicina en la universidad de
saskatchewan y dirige un programa médico
quirúrgico para los pacientes con
epilepsia en canadá
acaba lo interesante de esto es que
acaba de crear un programa que se llama
papel que significa programa de ayuda
para pacientes con epilepsia en
latinoamérica y es gratis
él está ofreciendo sus servicios desde
saskatchewan para cualquier persona de
américa latina que no la va a consultar
porque él es mexicano el español lo hace
en español pero está formado en méxico y
en canadá y uno ve el currículum de este
señor y me saco el sombrero y tu nota
dice bien que como él es mexicano se
siente en deuda porque méxico lo envió
aquí a especializarse y tenía que volver
pero como se enamoró por otras no uno
tiene un hijo enfermo y esa enfermedad
que tenía no existían remedios en manera
en canadá en méxico y por eso se quedó y
entonces él se siente en obligación y
devuelve va a seguido a méxico y hace
cosas en méxico bueno el tema es la
consulta cómo funciona es lo que dice
que los pacientes por ejemplo ahí está
todo en el sitio web le envíen un
resumen del problema un
electroencefalograma que dice que eso es
muy fácil se envía hoy por correo
electrónico como
y hablaba a leonardo y entonces hay un
equipo de médicos de saskatchewan que
deciden si el caso es pertinente o no
para ellos y entonces ellos se ponen en
contacto y atienden los sábados por ya
sea por skype messenger o teléfono que
pueden hablar una hora entonces qué tipo
de consultas es lo voy a decir
rapidísimo sobre medicamentos sobre el
diagnósticos incorrectos sobre si
cirugía o no que él dice que hay
neurólogos que todavía no creen en la
cirugía de epilepsia y entonces tenemos
que ir quitando todos los mitos dice esa
falsa información y en las opciones que
tiene un paciente y para terminar lo que
él dice es que conoce muchísimos médicos
en américa latina' va muy seguido y a
veces los pacientes no saben a dónde ir
o tienen un diagnóstico incorrecto él
los va a referir a esos médicos como en
bolivia argentina u otros países que
además el servicio es público de salud
una segunda opinión que siempre es
exacto y entonces en el sitio en el
reportaje abajo porque hay gente que ya
está preguntando abajo está el sitio
papel
información cómo hacer todo el trámite
está en español inglés y francés
entonces se consulta rafa martínez que
quiera no solamente unos segundos lo más
más más más
louis también tiene que quedar un minuto
y medio exacto yo hice una entrevista
con él se llama lorena vine él en él fue
adoptado cuando era muy pequeño por una
por una familia de quebec pero es
originario de nació en el perú entonces
ahora con otra chica que también fue
adoptada en korea manuel al ix su pena
escribieron un libro en realidad es un
libro en el que presentan imágenes e
historias de gente que fue adoptada aquí
en quebec hay 20.000 personas nada todas
aquí en quebec fueron a recorrer toda la
provincia los fotografiaron y todos son
gente que vive de todo el mundo
con nombres muy quebequenses porque la
mayoría cuando fueron adoptados les les
cambiaron de nombre le dieron un nombre
muy en francés pero tienen todo el
físico del país de origen de donde
vienen y claro son de acá acá crecieron
y todo
cuentan sus historias la historia del
abandono que sintieron que como lo
vivieron pero también la historia de
hacerse de una nueva familia en otro
país a través de la adopción
entonces el reportaje se llama los
colores de la adopción y estamos
buscando un subtítulo esto una cifra
20.000 los colores la adopción podría
ser vos podrías ser tú
es una historia tan común la de la
adopción es un tema de máximo 20 mil
para una población que evidencia el 7 y
no están todos es decir lo que ellos
explican es que generalmente los la
gente que fue adoptada no cuenta su
historia es la primera vez que son ellos
los muchos son generalmente los papás o
las familias que dejaron a sus hijos ir
entonces bueno que me dé tiempo varios
minutos más corta así que nos vamos con
con música antes despedimos a todos los
que hablo
también si está libre vuelve y el tema
de clyde que es una artista de
voluntario que va a estar pronto en unos
días más en el festival de música
canadiense en toronto su tema durante
rivero hasta la próxima
[Música]